Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Did you know that there is not just one type of burnout? Coming up today, we are looking
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会直接赢取Lisa提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。你知道吗？倦怠不仅仅只有一种类型。接下来，我们将探讨
at the three types of burnout that are distinctly different Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I love that every day is a school day and that we might have felt like we had a reasonable understanding of a particular psychology or mental health concept. And this is going to be a brilliant episode guiding us through the fact that there are actually three different types of burnout. So this can crop up for us at any stage of our life or career. You might notice this for your own personal insights for your life, or you might notice it for your professional life and I have loved learning about this. This is one of our special Burnout Bites series which is hosted for us expertly by Dr. Claire Plumley who is the author of a brand new book called Burnout
三种截然不同的倦怠类型。欢迎来到《准心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我喜欢每天都在学习的感觉，也喜欢我们有时会觉得自己对某个心理学或心理健康概念有合理的理解。这一集将非常精彩，它将引导我们了解实际上存在三种不同类型的倦怠。这可能在我们生活或职业生涯的任何阶段出现。你可能会在个人生活或职业生涯中察觉到这一点，我非常喜欢学习这些知识。这是我们特别的“倦怠小知识”（Burnout Bites）系列节目之一，由Claire Plumley博士专业主持，她也是一本全新著作《倦怠：
How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You and I'm taking a little bit of time off over the summer and passing the hosting reins over to Claire. You absolutely don't need to commit to listening to or watching all six of the episodes, but understandably they do build upon one another, but they are all standalone too. I can't wait to learn more about what these three types of burnout are. So let's crack on and I will catch you on the other side. Hello and welcome to Burnout Bites. This is number three in this series of six little episodes where I'm bringing information to help you understand burnout and ultimately look after yourself so
如何在神经系统控制你之前先控制它》（Burnout: How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You）的作者。我夏天会休假一段时间，并将主持工作交给Claire。你绝对不需要承诺听完或看完所有六集，虽然它们确实是循序渐进的，但每一集也都是独立的。我迫不及待地想了解这三种倦怠类型是什么了。让我们开始吧，稍后见。你好，欢迎收看“倦怠小知识”。这是六集系列节目中的第三集，我将在这里提供信息，帮助你了解倦怠，并最终照顾好自己，
that you don't burn out. My name is Dr. Claire Plumley. I'm a clinical psychologist and I specialize in trauma, anxiety and burnout. I've recently written a book. The book's called Burnout, How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You. And in this book, I bring my knowledge and learnings from my experience in trauma therapy and I bring this to this topic of burnout. There's a link to it in the show notes. In this episode, I want to talk to you about the three different subtypes of burnout. Now, I found this really useful when I learned about this, because think burnout is often considered as a kind of one type of thing, mostly exhaustion. But actually, this research by Barry Farber, Professor of Psychology and
这样你就不会精疲力竭。我是Claire Plumley博士。我是一名临床心理学家，专注于创伤、焦虑和倦怠领域。我最近写了一本书，书名是《倦怠：如何在神经系统控制你之前先控制它》。在这本书中，我结合了我在创伤治疗方面的知识和经验，并将其应用于倦怠这一主题。节目说明中提供了链接。在这一集中，我想和大家谈谈三种不同的倦怠亚型。当我了解到这一点时，我觉得非常有用，因为人们通常认为倦怠只有一种类型，主要是精疲力竭。但实际上，心理学和教育学教授Barry Farber针对治疗师和教师的研究表明，
Education, into specifically therapists and teachers, showed that it's not actually like that. There are three dominant subtypes and these are different ways of reacting to work-related stress. He also pointed out that we might oscillate between these at different times and I have recognised all three of these patterns at some point in my life so it'll be interesting to see what you think here too. So let's have a look. We've got three subtypes are frenetic, under-challenged and worn out. So the first one, frenetic, also often talked about as overburdened, is the subtype that we most commonly experience as burnout or looks most familiar when we use the word burnout. Well, frenetic working, working harder and harder in
事实并非如此。存在三种主要的亚型，它们是对工作相关压力的不同反应方式。他还指出，我们可能会在不同时间在这些模式之间摇摆，我也曾在自己生命中的某个时刻识别出所有这三种模式，所以看看你们对此有何感想会很有趣。让我们来看看。这三种亚型分别是：狂热型（frenetic）、挑战不足型（under-challenged）和耗竭型（worn out）。首先是“狂热型”，也常被称为“负担过重型”，这是我们最常体验到的倦怠类型，或者当我们使用“倦怠”这个词时最熟悉的样子。嗯，狂热地工作，为了应对压力而更加努力地工作。
response to stress. It happens when the demands of work outweigh the resources that we have access to, to do it comfortably, and often is married up with an ambition to do well. So your work-life boundaries start to slip. Work becomes all-encompassing. If you really passionately care about what you do, you're going to be vulnerable to this type of burnout. The typical trajectory of this through the domains of burnout tends to be that you start with a high anxiety irritability where you're frenetically working hard and your stress levels are high. This is followed by becoming physically exhausted by all of that energy output. This then leads to more emotional numbing and becoming cut off from it all, generally starting to disconnect from others from your surroundings and that cynicism
当工作需求超过了我们能够舒适完成工作的资源时，这种情况就会发生，而且通常伴随着想要做好的雄心。因此，你的工作与生活界限开始模糊。工作变得无处不在。如果你真的非常关心自己的工作，你就会容易受到这种倦怠的影响。这种倦怠在倦怠领域中的典型轨迹通常是：你先是感到高度焦虑和易怒，狂热地努力工作，压力水平很高。随后，由于能量过度消耗而感到身体疲惫。这进而导致更多的情感麻木，并与一切事物隔绝，通常开始与他人和周围环境脱节，愤世嫉俗的情绪
starts to set in of note is that this is particularly a problem in staff who are new to their jobs or have a new career and they're building their career because this is when we're particularly passionate and we've got that steep learning curve where we're trying to absorb a lot of information and do our best and often prove ourselves and work our way up the ladder so it's really important that you know about this if you are an aspiring psychologist potentially more vulnerable to this right now. Second we've got under-challenged burnout. This is sometimes I've heard referred to as bore out. So burnout doesn't just occur as a result of being overstretched. Monotonous work or work where there's no prospect of self-development is really under-stimulating.
开始出现。值得注意的是，这在刚入职或处于职业生涯起步阶段的员工中尤其是一个问题，因为这时我们特别有激情，正处于陡峭的学习曲线中，试图吸收大量信息，尽力表现并证明自己，努力向上攀登。所以，如果你是一名准心理学家，现在可能更容易受到这种倦怠的影响，了解这一点非常重要。第二种是“挑战不足型”倦怠。我有时听说这被称为“无聊倦怠”（bore out）。所以，倦怠不仅仅是因为过度劳累。单调的工作或没有自我发展前景的工作会让人感到非常缺乏刺激。
If you carry out repetitive tasks and there's a lack of variety in what you do, this can lead to this type of under-challenged burnout. You're not being mentally stimulated enough. Now the trajectory through this is that the tedium is what makes you cynical towards work. This then leads to feeling exhausted and detached and generally you start to become less effective because you're not maybe doing things as well as you used to. You're not really bothered. So you might not prepare for things like you used to. You might forget to do things you said you would. Perhaps the detachment is experienced as more of an indifference. So it might be very subtle, but watching out for that could be a sign that you might be in burnout. I've often seen this in people, for example, like parents
如果你从事重复性任务，且工作缺乏多样性，这可能导致这种“挑战不足型”倦怠。你的大脑没有得到足够的刺激。这种倦怠的轨迹是：枯燥乏味让你对工作产生愤世嫉俗的态度。这进而导致感到精疲力竭和疏离，通常你会开始变得效率低下，因为你可能不像以前那样把事情做好。你真的不在乎了。所以你可能不会像以前那样为事情做准备。你可能会忘记做你答应过的事情。也许这种疏离感更多表现为一种冷漠。所以它可能非常微妙，但留意这一点可能是你可能处于倦怠状态的信号。我经常在例如父母
or informal carers where they've got high need dependence there's a lot of repetition in preparing meals cleaning up tending to hygiene personal hygiene this can feel really monotonous without the intellectual stimulation going on but it can also happen in workplaces where you've got people who appear to have quite intellectually stimulating jobs but actually specialized or got to that level where they're not got as much variety in their day anymore so in my book i talk about a vet friend of mine who had a specialism but got to that level where they're not got as much variety in their day anymore. So in my book, I talk about a vet friend of mine who had a specialism, but actually said that her workload had become very, very samey. So it's kind of a double edged sword with specialising, I guess. And this is exactly what Barry Farber's work said that people who are high achieving can
或非正式护理人员身上看到这种情况，他们需要照顾高需求的人，准备饭菜、打扫卫生、处理个人卫生等工作有很多重复性，这可能会让人感到非常单调，缺乏智力刺激。但这也会发生在工作场所，有些人看起来从事着相当具有智力挑战的工作，但实际上已经专业化或达到了某种水平，以至于他们的日常工作不再有那么多多样性。所以，在我的书中，我谈到了一位兽医朋友，她有专业特长，但实际上她说她的工作量变得非常、非常千篇一律。所以我想，专业化是一把双刃剑。这正是Barry Farber的研究结果，即高成就者可能
be at greater risk of burnout, because they're needing that challenge and that stimulation to thrive. And if you've been in your job a long time you know everything back to front and inside out you might need to find ways to keep yourself protected from this and obviously that is a little bit of a double edged sword because I found when I moved into private practice that this under challenge type of burnout happened when I was just seeing one-to-one clients face-to-face having left the NHS I wasn't doing all the variety of things I used to do supervision meetings all sorts of different night away days and all these fun things and although I really enjoyed my work I wasn't being stimulated in the
面临更大的倦怠风险，因为他们需要那种挑战和刺激才能茁壮成长。如果你在工作中待了很长时间，对一切都了如指掌，你可能需要找到方法来保护自己免受这种倦怠的影响。显然，这有点像双刃剑，因为我发现当我转入私人执业时，当我离开国民医疗服务体系（NHS），只是面对面地接待一对一客户时，这种“挑战不足型”倦怠就发生了。我不再做以前做的各种多样化的事情，比如督导会议、各种夜间外出活动和所有这些有趣的事情。虽然我真的很喜欢我的工作，但我并没有得到我所需要的刺激，
way I needed and this is where I then started to take on other projects I started to do social media started to run a group started to write a book and then I had tipped into the kind of more frenetic burnout so yeah finding your balance between these is something I think that maybe is an ongoing lesson for me and something I'm always working on but helpful for maybe you to be mindful of as well so finally we've got the worn out type of burnout I've heard this referred to sometimes as brown out so this isn't about the volume of work or how stimulating it is. Rather, it relates to how aligned your work is with your personal values or sense of achievement you're getting from it.
这就是我开始承担其他项目的原因。我开始做社交媒体，开始组织小组，开始写书，然后我就陷入了更偏向“狂热型”的倦怠。所以，是的，在这些之间找到平衡是我认为可能对我来说是一个持续的教训，也是我一直在努力的事情，但对你来说，保持警惕可能也会有所帮助。最后，我们有“耗竭型”倦怠。我有时听说这被称为“暗淡倦怠”（brown out）。所以这与工作量或刺激程度无关。相反，它与你的工作与个人价值观或你从中获得的成就感的一致性有关。
For example, I worked for a department set up to help people improve their mental health with therapy. This was back in the NHS several years ago. But the targets that were pushing down on us affected how much I could see a client and how many sessions I could offer. This really did not work with my values. I wanted to offer good quality therapy in line with nice guidelines and instead I was being told I could only see them for x number of sessions for 45 minutes. I didn't have as much time to plan the sessions as I wanted and so I felt really frustrated in my ability to achieve what I wanted with my clients. So the typical trajectory here might be emotional exhaustion. As a starting point, you're feeling
例如，我曾为NHS的一个部门工作，该部门旨在通过治疗帮助人们改善心理健康。那是几年前的事了。但强加给我们的目标影响了我能接待客户的数量以及我能提供的疗程次数。这真的与我的价值观不符。我希望按照Nice指南提供高质量的治疗，但相反，我被告知只能为他们提供有限次数的45分钟疗程。我没有足够的时间来按照我想要的方式规划疗程，所以我对自己无法在客户身上实现目标感到非常沮丧。所以这里的典型轨迹可能是情感耗竭。作为起点，你感到
kind of low, this then physically weighs you down, you become detached. And the detachment is a form of self protection, protecting yourself and caring so much because caring isn't getting you anywhere that you want. And again, more experienced staff might be more susceptible to this. I think there are roles where all three of these can happen at once. So for example, imagine a GP, a GP only has 10 minutes to do their consultation, they might also end up seeing very similar cases day in day out. So there we've got the frenetic burnout where they've got too many people to see not enough time to do the work they want. we've got the frenetic burnout where they've got too many people to see, not enough time to do the work they want. We've got the worn out burnout where they're not aligned with the values giving their patients the amount of time that they would like. And you've got the
情绪低落，这在身体上让你感到沉重，你变得疏离。这种疏离是一种自我保护，保护自己不再投入过多的关心，因为关心并不能让你达到想要的结果。同样，更有经验的员工可能更容易受到这种倦怠的影响。我认为有些角色可能会同时出现这三种倦怠。例如，想象一位全科医生（GP），全科医生只有10分钟的时间进行咨询，他们可能最终每天都在处理非常相似的病例。所以在这里，我们有“狂热型”倦怠，因为他们要看太多病人，没有足够的时间来完成他们想要的工作。我们有“耗竭型”倦怠，因为他们无法按照自己的价值观给病人提供他们想要的时间。而且你还有
under-challenged burnout where they're not really doing enough that might stretch them unless they're involved with other projects. So whilst Barry Farber talked about oscillating between them, maybe it's possible to have all three at once. Triple whammy of burnout, which is really unpleasant. So I hope this has given you a bit of food for thought, maybe thinking about how to protect yourself from all three of these burnouts and being careful if you're trying to protect yourself from one that you don't inadvertently step into another one.
“挑战不足型”倦怠，因为除非他们参与其他项目，否则他们所做的事情并不能真正挑战他们。所以，虽然Barry Farber谈到了在它们之间摇摆，但也许有可能同时拥有这三种倦怠。三重倦怠打击，这真的非常令人不快。所以我希望这能给你带来一些启发，也许可以思考一下如何保护自己免受这三种倦怠的影响，并且在试图保护自己免受一种倦怠时，要小心不要无意中陷入另一种倦怠。
I look forward to seeing you in the next episode when I'm going to talk about the five stage model of burnout. How brilliant was that? I'm sure as you listened to or watched that content, you were able to think about how this might crop up for you in many areas of your life, both personal and professional. And I think they're really useful points to consider when you might be working with clients or when you might be chatting with your friends to think that actually, I wonder if this could be burnout. Thank you so much to Claire for episode three in this series. If you have enjoyed this episode, please do check out the other two that are already available. And the next episode will be available from 10am on
我期待在下一集中见到你，届时我将讨论倦怠的五阶段模型。那太棒了，不是吗？我相信当你听或看这些内容时，你一定能想到这在你的个人和职业生活的许多方面是如何出现的。我认为当你在与客户合作或与朋友聊天时，考虑到“我想知道这是否可能是倦怠”，这些是非常有用的观点。非常感谢Claire带来本系列的第三集。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必查看已经发布的前两集。下一集将于上午10点发布，
Saturday on YouTube, where I am Dr. Marianne Trent, and from 6am wherever you get your podcasts for the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Do come and follow me and Dr. Claire on socials. She is Dr. Claire Plumley, and I am Dr. Marianne Trent. Do also come and join the free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent, which is the exclusive home of Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions, which happen once a week. If you love this sort of content, I think you'll really enjoy. The aspiring psychologist membership and if working towards your goals for professional and if working towards your career goals in psychology is something on your to-do list then please do consider joining us which you can do from just
周六在YouTube上，我是Marianne Trent博士，从早上6点开始，你可以在任何获取播客的地方收听《准心理学家播客》。欢迎在社交媒体上关注我和Claire。她是Claire Plumley博士，我是Marianne Trent博士。也欢迎加入免费的Facebook群组“与Marianne Trent博士一起的准心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent），这是Marianne的动力和心态课程的独家基地，每周举行一次。如果你喜欢这类内容，我想你会非常喜欢“准心理学家会员计划”。如果朝着你的职业目标努力，
£30 a month with no minimum term. Thank you so much for being part of my world and I will look forward to catching up with you soon. Take care. Thank you. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease
如果朝着心理学职业目标努力是你的待办事项之一，那么请考虑加入我们，每月仅需30英镑，没有最低期限要求。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我期待很快与你交流。保重。谢谢。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。各种各样的途径让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家没有完美的路径，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得自己在做错什么，也减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你感到安心，
and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。